cosa è un etichetta secondo voi se non è
un etichetta è nata solamente per
soffocare limitare ciò che non riusciamo
a racchiudere in una prosa e oggi
entrando in quest'aula
ho notato una bottiglietta che proprio
davanti a noi ea un etichetta una
bottiglia e tv brasile che contiene che
cosa fondamentalmente acqua se non
riusciti gli esseri umani
noi siamo riusciti a brandizzare
ammettere una marca sulla cosa su cui
noi stessi siamo composti noi siamo
composti per la maggior parte di acqua
un etichetta quindi che cosa secondo me
un etichetta fondamentalmente un limite
un limite dal quale è difficile uscire
una volta che veniamo appunto
imbottigliati vediamo classificati per
la nostra nazionalità per il nostro
lavoro e la nostra età è una volta che
veniamo imbottigliati è difficilissimo
uscire
eppure noi siamo fatti di acqua siamo
flessibili possiamo fare un po tutto
dobbiamo solamente convincerci di
poterlo fare
e a me è costato quattro anni
convincerli di potercela fare perchè
perché sin dal 2007 mi hanno sempre
qualificato come un regista da quando ho
iniziato però non mi sono mai definito
tale per due motivi innanzitutto un
regista non è altro che una persona che
è riuscita ad acquistare talmente tanta
stima dal pubblico è talmente data
stimata gli addetti ai lavori tramite
film ho tanti o pochi ma fatti bene il
secondo punto perché comunque un regista
riesce a gestire una squadra una squadra
che viene da un produttore un produttore
che gli stanze un budget per pagare ogni
elemento di quella squadra
io come mi definisco se mi voglio
proprio imbottigliare però rimanendo su
un fiume
mi definisco come un cantastorie per il
cantastorie non ha bisogno per forza dei
riflettori non ha bisogno della fama non
ha bisogno di farsi il red carpet un
cantastorie può stare in una strada e
mettersi a raccontare alle persone senza
necessariamente avere un ritorno
economico senza necessariamente avere un
ritorno di fama
ci mette la racconti più fortunati a
volte venivano presi da dei mecenati che
poi infatti in futuro di vendere i
produttori stavano a casa e raccontavano
a un gruppo selezionato di persona
perché per fare un film però non puoi
tecnicamente essere un cantastorie
pensate che il più grande film
hollywoodiano fino adesso conta se non
mi sbaglio 3310 persone in media un film
hollywoodiano ne conta 588 per essere
realizzato e il settore più importante
in un film hollywoodiano è sempre quello
degli effetti speciali che in media
conta 156 persone
io non avevano i soldi per pagarmi tutte
queste persone ne avevo trovato un
produttore che potesse credere in me ma
era anche giusto perché comunque dopo
che fai corti nessuno è un pazzo da
affidarti un budget milionario per fare
un film di effetti speciali
io ero così pazzo che comunque volevo
fare il mio primo film lungo di 90
minuti con gli effetti speciali
naturalmente avevo due opzioni o mollo
tutto e continua a fare ai cortometraggi
a vita oppure decide di investire sul
mio stesso dando tutto quello che ho
ovvero non ho i soldi per pagare tutti
qua a tutte queste persone
ok quali sono le abilità importanti che
io devo imparare montaggio effetti
speciali scenografia sceneggiatura come
piazza la telecamera come piazza delle
luci ok non so come fare imparo elin
even uno dei concetti che mi rimane più
impresso della prima apre a lauren
economia ovvero la piramide di
management
puoi scegliere solamente due punti le
immagini che vede dietro o fai una cosa
bene e la fa in maniera economica che
quelle che scelsi io ma non la puoi fare
mai in maniera veloce quindi scelse di
farlo in maniera eco nome di farlo bene
ma non ci sarei mai potuto stare poco
tempo ci avrei impiegato tanto tempo non
sapevo ancora quanto ci impiegava la
fine quattro anni per fare questo film e
in questi quattro anni ho imparato una
cosa che era la cosa più importante che
forse mi rimase durante tutto questo
percorso è la cosa più importante era
che io sto investendo su me stesso e
l'unico punto che io decisi
di delegare a un'altra persona fu
appunto un settore in particolare del
film che è l'audio riuscire a racimolare
dei soldi e dissi ok faccio tutto però
l'audio logistici tu questa persona
disse ok ma dopo un mese il progetto la
sua parte non era completa dopo due mesi
stessa cosa tra me
passarono sei mesi e l'audio non era
completo se questa persona scomparve
però siccome ero amici ci passa sopra
persi i soldi ma non era la cosa che mi
interessava ad aver perso i soldi quale
ovviamente è stato dopo tre anni e mezzo
che ci lavoravo e che avevo perso altri
sei mesi e che avrei dovuto imparare
anche a fare audio allora dissi ok ho
perso sei mesi ne investo 12 mesi per
fare il resto
bega e sei mesi per registrare 9000
suoni per questo film di animazione
stavo per uscire pazzo ma li imparare
una cosa che potevo perdere gli amici
potevo perdere soldi ma se perdevo tempo
quella era la risorsa che non sarebbe
mai più tornata indietro
da lì in quel momento io decisi di farmi
coraggio di quelle poche abilità che
avevo imparato perché quelle abilità
riuscivano a darmi indipendenza sembra
una follia colore sto dicendo però
adesso dopo tutti i software che ho
imparato dopo tutte quelle piccole cose
che ho imparato durante questo film io
so che qualora io mi dovesse affidare
una seconda persona una terza persona
io so che qualora quella persona
scompaia io comunque ho dentro di me
quella piccola consapevolezza che
qualora ha finito a spalle al muro
posso ancora alzarmi a camminare perché
l'abilità ti dà indipendenza e
l'indipendenza di rafforza fa capire che
comunque quel tempo non è stato perso
ce l'hai dentro di te però naturalmente
stiamo parlando di un film che sto
facendo con 13 mila euro di budget
attuali e quindi non me la potevo andare
a competere con un film di 180 milioni
di dollari fatto appunto da tutte quelle
persone né tantomeno volevo cercare di
sfidarlo però è normale che un film di
180 milioni di dollari è diverso da un
film fatto con 10.000 dollari e
addirittura le mie i miei complimenti
erano inferiori rispetto a un film dal
budget normale
le mie capeggiato re principale era una
felpa verde che ora vi spiego perché due
luci da giardino è una telecamera la
felpa verde perché emule il green screen
cos'è un green screen per chi non lo sa
se in questo momento dietro di me adesso
invece di un muro bianco ad essi un
pannello verde un green screen
io riuscirei a con tramite il computer
tramite gli effetti speciali a togliere
questo green screen e a proiettarmi in
qualsiasi altra parte del mondo se ci
fate caso non è per forza che un attore
holliwoodiano deve andare sul
sull'everest viene fatto in uno studio
di registrazione e poi viene ritagliato
l'attore e viene messo sull'everest
questo tagli costi di produzione
nel mio caso siccome volevo fare un film
completamente originale
il mio personaggio era una mano quindi a
me la fetta verde mi andava bene anche
perché comunque non lo sarebbe potuto
permettere uno schermo grande e il mio
computer
ero un computer da 15 pollici con 512 mb
di ram per chi non capisce di computer
come me ai tempi
praticamente se andavo a manovella ero
più veloce però alla fine lavorando e 25
minuti a fotogramma riuscì ad avere
degli effetti speciali che comunque non
sembravano da un film di 13 mila euro
ma proprio perché lavorai sul fotogramma
pensate che per ogni secondo di video ci
sono 25 fotogrammi oltre 24 volte 30 me
nel mio caso 25 e proprio i fotogrammi
25 minuti proprio perché computer molto
lento ma alla fine anche quando il
soggetto iri movimento io riuscirò a
mantenere un equilibrio grafico che mi
permettesse non di arrivare ai livelli
holliwoodiani ma comunque di non
sembrare da un film da 13 mila euro
quello era il mio obiettivo ma
naturalmente cosa succedeva che sono
passati due anni già dei quattro anni di
cui vi ho raccontato e stanno iniziando
a uscire pazzo non solo io pazzo ma
anche con quelle persone mio volo
benediciamo vincenzo prima facevo in
corto al mese e adesso e due anni e che
cosa abbiamo è finito il suo film
no veramente se avevo fatto ancora
trenta minuti o che fammi vedere una
scena completa e non c'erano scene
complete erano scene sparse perché tutto
il film avevo qui in testa per ogni
volta che cercavo un attimo di
incoraggiamento e c'era solamente
sfiducia dice la questura sono già
finisce mai questo team e la sfiducia
stava prendendo corpo anche in me
impara una cosa che il nostro perché di
qualsiasi cosa che sia una laurea che
sia uno studio che se un qualsiasi cosa
un lavoro il nostro perché deve essere
più grande della sfiducia non sono della
sfiducia che abbiamo attorno e quella
minore alla sfiducia che si inizia a
creare dentro di noi con diciamo non ce
la faccio più non ce la faccio più
voglio uscire
voglio avere una vita normale più stare
chiusi in questa casa in quel momento io
avevo due opportunità ormai era questo
film era diventato come una sorta di
imprese subacquee una sorta di apnea
vero sceso talmente giu
era difficile risalire su non ce la
facevo più stanno uscendo pazzo ma se mi
fossi messo a spiegare a sinistra a
destra
fidatevi di me sfida di fidati che ce la
faccio fidati che alla fine ci sarà un
risultato
io avrei perso tempo e ossigeno e
soprattutto in un momento di appena
quando è sott'acqua e devi pensare
solamente a risalire anche solamente per
non uscire pazzo non ti puoi mettere a
fare movimenti che non sono programmati
nella risalita
perché quando ti muovi per di ossigeno
se perdi ossigeno non è quello che ti
critica che affoga sei tu e quindi quel
momento decisi e il silenzio sarebbe
stata la mia più fondi la fonte più
grande della mia energia non dovevo
mettermi a spiegare più niente a nessuno
ma mista stavo perdendo la mia
motivazione principale perché amia per
direzione principale a fare qualcosa che
non era mai stato visto prima ma quello
e se ci fate come se la gloria personale
è una motivazione personale e con la
motivazione personale ci corre i 100
metri
la moratoria non la vinci ci crepi sul
circuito se non trovi una motivazione
più grande
ero stanco e vidi una telecom e una
telecamerina secondaria e disse sai che
cosa faccio ora per non uscire pazzo
inizio a registrare il dietro le quinte
parlando con un tool immaginario con una
persona che non esiste inizia a spiegare
qualsiasi cosa sto facendo
tipo art attack praticamente e spiegavo
sai come sto facendo il carrello io non
ho 3 mila euro per comprarlo
lo sto facendo tramite le ruote dello
skateboard è una pedana lilla in totale
cioè speso 100 euro in spiegare tutto
come stanno facendo gli effetti speciali
come stava facendo il montaggio tutto a
mia madre ogni tanto entrava diciamo
queste pazzini
perché hai che vedeva la telecamera
seconda dice questo corna è uscito ti
sento completamente mio padre entrava
apriva la porta diceva ma vabbè chiudeva
e quindi io continuavo a parlare eppure
sembra una cosa allucinante ma il sapere
che questi video sarebbero stati visti
oggi domani i trecento anni duemila anni
un ragazzo in nepal in qualcosa su
youtube uno sbaglia e clicca sapevo che
mi stava dando la forza di finire questo
film
paradossalmente queste persone
immaginare che poi un giorno avrebbero
visto queste cose ne avrebbero dato la
forza di finire questo film
ed è lì che ho imparato una cosa se io
dovessi scegliere cosa buttare il film o
dietro le 15 squadra sei su una torre
cosa buttiamo il film o buttiamo
indietro e quindi il documentario di
corda butta il film perché comunque ci
sono già i miliardi di film è un film e
una gloria personale c'è una firma
dietro lascia il documentario di come ho
fatto questo film perché comunque può
dare una mano e lì ho imparato e come
fare qualcosa a volte è più importante
del suo risultato finale perché tifa
paese ti fa sentire parte di una catena
ti fa sentire parte di una persona che è
riuscita a dare una mano al prossimo
così com'è stata inventata la ruota poi
grazie alla ruota è stata diventata la
macchina grazie alla macchina è stata
inventata la eredi nel mio piccolo dato
un documentario su come ho fatto questo
film che può dare un po di coraggio a un
vincenzo futuro che sta attraversando un
momento di sfiducia personale e generale
e di lì che ho capito che è la vera
forza non sta nella aiutare se stessi
nel trionfare la vera forza sta nel e
aiutare il prossimo anno la mano